I was scrolling through my Instagram the other day when I realized
Lots of selfies.  Which reminds me...
And even though social media is kind of technically my job
we live in a world that tells us that looking prettier means more
of everything.  More compliments.
You look like a girl with a lot of cats!
More tips.
Hi, how can I help you?
Hey you're pretty.
Oh, thank you--
You're pretty!
Oh, okay.  Th-thank you.
More opportunities.
Hey.
Ew.  Never.
I'm rich.
Ew.  Go buy me a bunch of drinks.
Attention, affection, visibility, likes, views, subscribers
and on and on and on.
And there has been scientific proof on attractive privilege.
Just like white or rich privilege, there are benefits to being attractive.
And this kind of brought me to the question:
Oh my God.  Am I narcissistic?  No!
I'm not narcissistic.  I mean yeah, I've put a considerable amount of time analyziing
how I could brand myself as a Leading Lady forcing me to work out, learn how to apply my make up
get my nails done, enhance my stupid straight eye lashes with eyelash-extensions so I never have to
curl them again. I mean I did it for my birthday once and now I'm addicted.  Shut up.
And it really started making me think about how social media not only makes it so easy
to get wrapped up in ourselves, but kind of makes you fine tune your appearance and like
wanna strive to be better and how you know the right angle for a selfie.
And it was just like ewh!
Like I don't want to be that.
But what about you?  Do you ever think about how the internet has affected our level of self-involvement?
And if it has made us more narcissistic or not?
I like to think that I'm not narcissistic but sometimes I wonder if I'm hiding behind the excuse that like
Oh, I'm an actress.  I have to think about what I look like.  In Hollywood you have to be beautiful
or you're not going to have a career.
But I don't really know and I'm genuinely afraid sometimes that I'm going to be a narcissist.
But then I'm like:  Oh, as long as I'm aware like, it wont happen, it's fine.
But who knows?
I'm Anna Akana.  Oh and, before I go--my make up just looks real good today so I'm going to just snap one.
Just kidding.  I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.  Or attractive.